gather round it is that time for CBS
morning's deals where we show you items
that might help you save some time and
some money all at exclusively low prices
and they might just become Essentials in
your everyday life if you want to start
shopping now you can scan the QR code on
your screen there upper left and you can
also visit cbsdeals.com right now we've
got lifestyle expert Liliana Vazquez
with more on all this Leona welcome
thank you for having me this is an item
I wish was available to me before my
child got into a high chair doesn't need
this anymore I know so basil baby is
genius they are all about making
self-feeding and eating fun and not as
messy so I am a new newish mom I have a
14 month old son Santiago I think y'all
saw in a tease earlier so we love these
at our house because here's the thing
when babies are self-feeding 90 of the
food doesn't actually make it in their
mouth it makes it into this extra large
pocket right here so it's great for them
it helps them be independent
[Applause]
I mean as a parent it keeps it off the
floor yes which makes cleanup easy for
parents but you can also just throw
these in the dishwasher you see how easy
they roll up so you can throw it in your
diaper bag great for on the go because
we're taking our babies out to
restaurants right like we're taking
airplanes everywhere so super portable I
love the extra large pocket road trips
keep your car clean and it's very light
it is really light and you can adjust
them so it's from four months all the
way to 24 months I absolutely love them
they're also a great gift so
grandparents if you're out there
thinking of great gifts amazing deal on
this you guys normally 18.99 I'm saving
y'all 35 off you get a two pack for 12
bucks they're basically six dollars each
okay it's a great deal and it's going to
save the clothes as well it's like
you're gonna go with things down the
front you know that yellow and the red
you know that's a good idea what she
says 35 yeah I got it you know I love a
deal right it's got to be a good deal if
it's here today okay so this is the
react by Limitless this is amazing it is
a seven in one emergency mini tool now
what I love about this is that this is
ready to help you in any emergency
situation big or small it's one of those
items that you know you don't realize
how badly you need it until you don't
have it right and especially with
everything that's happening right now
with so many emergency situations
happening there you go that's one of the
many many features there's seven in one
that is a personal alarm and I actually
love that you set that off so I love to
take my son for walks that's what we do
together that's how we spend time
together but when I'm alone with him
walking in the stroller I throw this in
my bag it's super portable it gives me
an added sense of safety flashlight
super bright throw this in your car it's
a seat belt cutter it's a power bank
it's a car charger yes right in here so
if you were in an emergency situation
how much is it so here's the deal on
this one you guys normally fifty dollars
saved you fifty percent off on this one
under 25 bucks so you can afford to give
the gift of safety to your loved ones
what is this okay this is really cool
this is really cool I love this one this
is the clean light Air Pro it is a
personal importable air purifier so
think about those big air purifier
systems in your house you can't pack
that up and take it with you can you now
you can and with this I traveled here
from La yesterday I threw this in my
purse second thing after I packed my
phone set it up on my little Airline
tray table and it filters the air around
you so it's filtering out things like
smoke odor yes that is right and it's
fully chargeable it runs for about four
hours on a single charge or you can plug
it in you can leave it in your car I
love it for hotel rooms how large of the
room does it cut so it's about a one
bedroom size right so a small one
bedroom size it's super quiet listen all
four of these are running right now do
you hear anything nothing whisper quiet
great for high traffic areas like your
cubicle your desk your car the deal on
this okay so good
189 99 but y'all 100 off today okay 100
making it
one
one there you go an end zone dance right
there that's a great deal it is a great
incredible deal it's a necessity oh yeah
that is absolutely and it's lightweight
super importantly does it clean the air
so what it does is it uses UVC lights no
I love this question so it uses the UV
light to clean those pollutants it also
uses negative technology thank you very
much and we do partner with all of these
companies to get you these incredible
deals to purchase anything you saw today
scan the QR code on your screen or visit
CBS News
cbsdeals.com we'll be right back